[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to a webinar part of the
lab roots coronavirus virtual event
series
my name is elizabeth schneider i'm a
senior global marketing manager here at
nanastring
today we have the pleasure for the first
presentation of this chronovirus virtual
event
to have two speakers here today to talk
about
tackling covid19 by looking at
temporal and spatial expression of
infected tissue and infectious samples
from patients and convalescent
individuals
up first today we have dr eugenia ong
she is a senior research fellow
at the viral research and experimental
medicine center
at singapore health duke and us
the acronym viremix and the duke and u.s
medical school and she works on the
development of
virological immunological and genomic
assays to determine the molecular
correlation for pre-clinical development
and efficacy monitoring of therapeutics
and vaccines
and she will be speaking today on the
temporal dynamics of the host
molecular response underlying severe
cod19 progression
and disease resolution we will
be collecting questions throughout the
presentation
and we will pause before we move on to
our next speaker
to take the questions for dr aung so
please go ahead and submit your
questions throughout the presentation
and then we will hold them until the end
for the q a discussion
and with that thank you very much dr
aung for being here
we're really looking forward to hearing
your presentation
yeah it's my pleasure elizabeth so uh
a large thank you to nano string and lab
roots uh for providing this platform and
opportunity for us to share our work
today with you
so the work that i'm going to be
describing it to you today
is on the temporal dynamics of the host
molecular responses
that underlie severe covet 19
progression and disease resolution
and this work was recently published in
ebar medicine in march
2021 and so i think coveted 19 is
is no stranger to anyone who is on this
webinar today
um today there have been more than 135
million coveted 19 cases worldwide
with deaths arising from covet 19
creeping towards
three million cases worldwide and so
since um
the covet-19 pandemic started i think
multiple
groups around the world have been um
have been trying to
um look at the underlying immune factors
for covet-19 severity and so here uh
what what we've done is uh we've
summarized the um events that happened
during both the acute phase of illness
as well as recovery phase
to give you just a flavor of the types
of
immune factors that could underlie covet
19 severity
and so in the acute phase of disease
what multiple groups have found is that
the host immune system feels to launch a
robust type 1 type 3 interferon response
we also see increased numbers of
inflammatory monocytes neutrophils
there is some degree of lymphopenia as
well as exhausted t cell responses
as well as increased levels of
pro-inflammatory cytokines such as il-6
and interferon gamma
that could be predictive of disease
severity
in contrast during the recovery phase we
see recovery of t
cells including mammary cd80 cells as
well as the recovery of dendritic cell
subsets
there is also reduced um numbers of
neutrophils
as well as increased basophils and
eusynofields as well as a reduced
level of il-6 interferon gamma as well
as cxl10 during the recovery phase
however seeding the causative from the
associated factors of respiratory
dysfunction remains an urgent unmet need
the host responses that cause
respiratory function
we think would track most closely with
disease progression and resolution
and therefore permit differentiation
from other factors that could be just
statistically associated with but not
causative
of severe covid19 and therefore the
statistical association with covet
19 could also be heavily influenced by
something points in the course of
acute uranus and so in our research what
we've done
is to focus on the host response to
saskov2 infection around the period of
the media of respiratory function
and be sampled daily from 19 patients
whenever possible and so our hypothesis
is that the principal drivers of
covet-19 severity should track tightly
with respiratory function
and should also resolve in sync with
respiratory improvement
and so you'll see that on the table on
the left hand side
is a table showing clinical features of
patients that were included in our study
consisting of 10 patients 8 male and 2
female patients
patients range from disease severity
from
mild to moderately severe to severe and
on the right hand side
you'll see an overview of the of the
sampling points that were taken from
these patients over the course of
disease
and this ranges from around negative
four days to 13 days postnatal year with
day zero being the day of nadiya
for most of this time points you'll see
that we we would have done sampling
that was uh eventually that we then
eventually sent for both microarray as
well as nanostream profiling
and so we use oxygen requirement to
stratify patients into mild moderately
severe or severe covate 19
and after 10 patients four were
classified as mouth as they did not
require supplemental oxygen
and for the remaining six patients uh
for which you could
you can see their clinical overview on
the left hand side of the screen
the all patients here required of
supplemental oxygen
and five patients required more than two
liters per minute of supplemental oxygen
requiring either
mechanical ventilation or um the usage
of high flow oxygen
devices while the remaining patient who
was moderately severe
receive not more than two liters per
minute of supplemental oxygen
the um severe covate19 patients also
display
leukemia as shown on the chart on the
right hand side
despite normal white blood cell counts
and this is also consistent with
findings from
other groups
so we sampled blood daily from patients
where possible
and fall and this was followed by rna
extraction from whole blood
before the rna was then sent for
microarray profiling
and so on the left hand side of the
screen you'll see a waterfall plot
that shows differentially expressed
genes
that were detected over the course of
disease in patients
and these differentially expressed genes
are
expressed with a full change of more
than 1.5
with an adjusted p value of less than
0.05
um when we conducted functional
implementation of downregulated genes
um it revealed that the immune pathways
were to most significantly reduce the
time as shown on the
plot on the right hand side of the
screen and this included
pathways such as cytokine and interferon
dependent immune responses
inflammatory signaling as well as
neutrophil-mediated
immune pathway to be more significantly
reduced with time
in contrast we did not find negan
pathways
among the upregulated genes
we next validated changes in the
expression of innate and adaptive immune
genes using nanostring profiling and so
conducting a principal component
analysis confirmed
that covet 19 patients segregated
distinctly from healthy controls
which consisted of baseline samples that
were obtained
from participants of a measles mums and
rubella revaccination study
so we can see that top contributors in
gc1 consider
consisted of genes that were involved in
prolactin receptor signaling as well as
inflammatory responses
and this was important for
distinguishing the
mouth from the severe patients in
addition the top contributors in pc3
which differentiated healthy controls
from patients with covet-19 included
genes that were driving the cytokine as
well as the interferon responses
from nanostring profiling what we found
was that the top down regulated genes
included pathways such as prolight
receptors as well
as the type 1 interferon signaling
pathways which was consistent with what
we had found
with microarray in addition the immune
pathways that were upregulated during
the recovery phase
included pathways that could be related
to t-cell proliferation and activation
interestingly as you see on this slide
when we plotted out these
gene expression profiles temporally the
expression profiles for these pathways
suggest that suppression of the type 1
interferon and prolight receptor
signaling pathways
actually precedes restoration of the
t-cell proliferation
and activation pathways and the
heat maps on the screen right here
reflect this
very clearly
so to determine the genes that track
with disease progression and resolution
we next use extraction and analysis of
differential gene expression or
edge analysis to obtain greater insight
on the
temporally regulated transcripts over
the course of illness in severe patients
so from edge analysis we identified 4831
temporally regulated genes
um which following that were put through
self-organizing map clustering
and um through this process uh you'll
see that these genes
there's actually distinct
transcriptional dynamics that are shown
in severe patients
and they happen to segregate into two
distinct
molecules so genes and module a are
shown to be
decreased post nadia where whereas genes
and modularity are increasing post media
and so we think that combining edge as
well as self-organizing maps clustering
or som clustering
allowed us to leverage both the clinical
as well as temporal covariates
for increased statistical power to
identify genes that track with
disease progression as well as recovery
so if we were to perform a powerful
analysis of genes that were shown to be
decreasing
postnatal what we identified was that
genes are implicated in cellular
responses type one
interferon the regulation of immune
effector functions
as well as neutrophil-mediated immunity
so of note
i like to focus on the um the pathway
for neutral field-mediated immunity
which is
the most significantly and rich pathway
found in
clusters three and four and as you can
see from the bar plots on the right hand
side of the screen
well at the bottom right hand side of
the screen the gene expression profile
for genes that are driving neutrophil
mediated immunity seem to track very
well with both disease progression
as well as disease recovery so of note
neutral fuel activation as well as the
presence of neutrophil extracellular
trap markers
have been observed in the lung of covert
19 patients in post-mortem examinations
and besides covet 19 neutrophils have
also been found to be enriched in the
lungs of patients with
acute respiratory distress syndrome
caused by other infections such as
influenza
and we think that because of this
context it provides a greater clinical
relevance for pathways that have been
identified in our analysis
so significant pathway enrichment was
derived
from genes in cluster six and so these
are the genes
so next what we focused on were genes
that were
shown to be increasing postnatal and we
found significant pathway enrichment
only
derived from genes in cluster six and so
in these genes what we saw was an
increased protein phosphorylation
signature
in covate 19 patients that were
recovering from severe disease
and so of the 36 genes that were
significantly are regulated in the
protein phosphorylation
pathway and 20 were found to serine
threonine kinases as shown on the heat
map on the right hand side of the screen
interestingly when these genes were
cross-referenced to red force
so regfos is a database that allows
exploration of the human protein
phosphorylation regulatory network
we found that these genes were involved
in cell growth cell survivor as well as
t cell development
um suggesting that kinases could play a
protective role in disease resolution
and indeed we think that perhaps protein
phosphorylation could be key
to restoring t cell numbers during the
recovery of illness as we had shown
earlier
in the heat map from before
now since genes in cluster 3 and 4
or those that are responsible for
neutrophil activation as well as
inflammatory responses are strongly
associated with disease progression and
resolution
uh what we did next was to cross
reference these transcripts to the drug
gene interaction database
or dgidb and the
candidate drugs that you see on the left
hand side are a result of
that analysis that was done so
the drugs that target genes in cluster
three and four or genes that
are decreasing post nadia are shown in
blue
and the drugs that target genes in
cluster three and four but not genes in
cluster six are highlighted in pink
and this identifies differentially drugs
that
um could target genes that are
downregulated postnatal but not those
that are increasing personally to
prevent any
um of target effects
and so the candidate drugs that
corroborate with drugs that have shown
efficacy outcomes in clinical trials
including
dexamethasone and aspirin are shown
highlighted here on the plots on the
left
and in contrast drugs with no efficacy
in improving clinical
outcomes such as lupineville retinovir
as well as hydroxychloroquine
were absent from the hits
so in summary we think that by
performing daily transcriptomic
profiling of severe and non-severe
covalent 19 patients
our findings reveal that neutrophil
activation but not type 1 interferon
signaling transcripts
track most closely with disease
progression and recovery
and so drugs that target neutrophil
activation could be
repurposed for the for the treatment of
severe covet 19
um and collectively our data serves as a
resource for understanding the
post-pathogen dynamics
involved in coveting disease progression
as well as recovery
so lastly i'd like to acknowledge our
collaborators and colleagues
at both the singh health deep and us
academic
medical center by mix the singapore
general hospital as well as duke and us
medical school
we thank all doctors and nurses in the
isolation facility at the singapore
general hospital
and this study was sponsored in part by
a generous grant from the hourglass
and i thank you for your attention and
your time
thank you so much um dr aung that was a
really
uh insightful presentation so
a couple of questions came in throughout
the course of the presentation
so the first question for you
there are many reports on sequela caused
by coven 19
and survivors including loss of hearing
taste and even
psychological conditions do you foresee
possible blood-based biomarkers that can
be developed in the future to predict
and intervene
um with such um you know symptoms and
effects yeah so
um that's definitely an interesting um
question
and um the use of blood-based biomarkers
i think
is definitely possible in in the long
run um
we are actually we have already done
some initial testing
using this approach for assessing safety
signals for adverse events
um for example our group had actually
done a previous study on the yellow
fever vaccine
which is actually one of the most
effective vaccines today
and the just over 50 percent of vaccine
recipients they actually report adverse
events
after receiving the yellow fever vaccine
and adverse events can
include symptoms such as fatigue
headaches as well as muscle aches and
what we showed was that after
yellow fever dosing the activation of
innate immune genes at day one but not
day three after vaccination was directly
correlated with
the onset of adverse events so i think
that
a marker approach is certainly possible
but
there are similarly also challenges that
we have to
challenges or practical considerations
that we have to
take note of um and i think the first
one would be
how these survivors are recruited so the
recruitment process
and probably this would involve a
multi-disciplinary team as
as you mentioned these symptoms actually
intersect various organ classes
and ideally i think these
these survivors would be followed up at
primary care providers that could then
possibly refer them to enroll in
clinical research studies
and the second point of consideration
would be how something would be
performed
and i think this would be most the most
challenging part because um
there is an uncertainty in terms of the
time points that need to be
collected and so um it's really
important i think that you have a
systematic study design that can capture
time points
uh both before during and after such uh
sequelae um happens in order to get
a good set and a robust set of data for
for the type of analysis that needs to
take place in order to identify these
black biomarkers
thank you so another question came in
have you done any t-cell receptor
based sequencing to look at
what types of you know t-cell receptors
are being displayed in some of these
patients and
individuals in particular to kind of
understand
you know whether or not the t cells are
able to
coalesce around a single
receptor repertoire and
also what implications that has on
you know previous um you know viruses
that people
who have severe covet have been exposed
to
and you know whether or not their t cell
receptors you know
quickly recognize the virus or if
if they you know the t cell receptors
have trouble
um sort of um narrowing down on the
right receptor
that can help combat the virus
yeah so this is another interesting
question and
i think it's extremely relevant in the
context of
the tcr related findings that we've made
whereby we see that there is a
restoration of the transcriptional
signatures for
genes driving t cell activation and
proliferation
um so my short answer is no we have not
done
those studies in our lab but my
understanding is that
um from the literature now i think there
are multiple reports coming out
um that show both
the importance of t cells and mediating
um protection
both in the vaccine context as well as
in a
sas cough two infection contexts um
and um indeed there was a paper coming
out from um
a group in duke and u.s medical school
and this group is led by
antonio bertoletti um his lab has
actually shown that
in black in convalescent blood that was
collected from
the previous um sas coronavirus one
[Music]
survivors so singapore
actually faced a sas epidemic in 2003
and so this is nearly about 20 years
after the
initial infections they still had
cross-reactive t cells
that uh that could protect against
suscoff2
so i think that um collectively
this shows that t cells remain a very
important weapon
in the asana of our host defense against
saskov2
great thank you and we have time for one
more question another question
came in through the chat for any of
these
patients is there any chance that you
might have
some tissue samples to look at
to try to understand more on the virus
side
what tissues the virus initially
infiltrated
in other words trying to understand from
more of the virus perspective what route
were the individuals infected you know
by
whether it was you know respiratory or
gastrointestinal etc
and maybe how that might affect the
outcomes in terms of the severity
um in in the process of collecting these
samples from patients um
uh we were actually only able to collect
um whole blood samples
so unfortunately we don't really have
tissue samples that
can be analyzed but i think other groups
have now also performed
[Music]
different types of using different
approaches such as
things such as post-mortem examinations
and
clearly i think the lungs are always the
um
the uh the tissue types that are most
severely damaged both by over-exuberant
inflammatory response
as well as infiltration of immune cells
and um i i think that um
that that that uh really sets the stage
for uh the type of um
uh infection that sucks coffee causes
which is one that
um causes a lot of tissue and organ
damage in the lungs
excellent well thank you so much dr aung
oh
it looks like there's one more question
that came in really quick before we wrap
up and i know that you you have limited
time with us
um so i'll see if we can get this
question in really quick
um so someone asked you know how easy is
the nanostring
encounter technology to use with
biofluid samples compared to say doing
pcr or rna sequencing
well so in our experience i think using
encounter has been
extremely useful because it shortens the
amount of time needed
um by by a very large extent
and so um in instead of
you know performing um real-time pcr
um about maybe five to ten
times we were we were able to save on
the
amount of rna that we had in the lab and
use use that amount of rna for just
running the encounter essay once
to get a simultaneous readout for over
500 immune genes and i think that has
been very useful
in preserving the amount of
the rna rna that we have remaining from
these collected samples so that we may
likely be able to use them in future
studies
yeah excellent thank you so much and i
just would like to point out as well for
everyone who's joining us
for this presentation that um dr aung
and her colleagues did use the encounter
immunology and inflammation
gene expression panels but in response
to the coca-19 pandemic
last year nanostring did launch
a panel specifically for studying the
host response
to infectious disease and it's called
the host response panel
and we have a human and a mouse version
that you can use in your research
well thank you so much dr aung it was a
pleasure for having you
and um we will have the next speaker up
all right everyone so we're back for our
second presentation
as part of the nana string sponsored
webinar
for the lab roots coronavirus virtual
event series
so next up i would like to introduce dr
jio yong he uh
is part of the institute of molecular
and cell biology
a star in singapore so he's an associate
faculty there
he is also affiliated with the division
of pathology
at singapore general hospital and today
he's going to be
speaking to us about understanding the
spatial immune
micro environment proximal to sars kobe
2 viral antigen
and rna and covid19 decedents and
survivors
by using spatial transcriptomics and
again we will
have a question and answer session at
the end of
dr yong's presentation so please go
ahead and put your questions through the
chat
and we will address them at the end of
the presentation
also for those of you who had questions
for dr aung's presentation
and your questions weren't answered we
will collect
questions and follow up with them at a
later time
to address all of your questions so
thank you again um
dr young we're very looking forward to
your presentation
thank you thank you uh deserve it so uh
thank you for inviting me i mean today
i'm actually
very happy to actually share with you
this particular
topic about understanding the spatial
immune micro environment proximal to
suscoft2 viral antigen and as well as
rna
in covate 19 dissidence and survival by
using spatial transcriptomics
technology i have no uh computer
interest
so and we all know that nowadays
special technologies to actually study
uh tissue
is a very important things i mean i
it's actually a involvement from you can
see
initially we i mean like we only have
hashing e and i have
the under the bright field to study the
tissue and that is actually
still a golden standard for for the
diagnosis
for especially cancer and uh for the
past you know five or ten years i mean
like the multiplexer has you is actually
our view
i mean it's also very hot topic
to actually heart technology to which it
started cancer immune micro environment
or other diseases that require
microscopy setting
so this one is actually at the moment is
is
is still very important however there
are many
uh you know advanced technologies coming
out
and then all this uh something that we
want to you know introduce to you today
as well
and and and you know most of the people
also understand that they are either
player like you know hyperion
uh from fudai uh for example
eb uh all this uh we will call it
advanced technology they are
more useful for research and discovery
and you can see that we actually uh put
them into like a
involvement that you know from the
clinical translational and research that
you know
based on their cost and all time and
technical barriers
and just to recap and just in case
you're not very sure why spatial
technology and why is the
why is the the the technology that
people mostly use
multiplex is basically one tissue
section that traditionally you only can
do one color staining
study one or two biomarker at the moment
you can do easily six
or nine or even 50 that came by some of
the technologies or even more
so i mean our groups are specialized in
this
area i mean like if you are interested
please you know use your mobile to
actually get the qr code
uh in here you all can you can see some
of our
data that will diversity into public
domain and you can play with them
alive and all this thing including this
particular image this is a very
interesting
platform that we developed we will talk
about it later on as well
so uh
sorry um what is spatial transatomics
why we are actually using it so as you
know
generally if you do about rna sequencing
it generally looks like this so you are
sequencing everything
in the tissue is like a mix of cells a
mix of
different tissue type kind of things
right
so in a single cell's uh era
you know you can sort the cells it can
it can run through all the single cells
are selling or even you know without
something you run through all the
singles
and then do you do a clustering later on
you can just study different cell type
in a single sound levels
that is the you know there is a
relatively new technology as well right
so for the spatial transatomics what do
we do pressure transform is basically
just to
use actually look at all these single
cells
and to make them back into the spatial
information setting so you can see that
you actually know which cell type
actually located where and which kind of
spatial morphology and organ setting
and it is actually represent very well
the functional tissue there's a real
tissue
the only thing only difference is that
the real digit is a 3d
structures rather than 2d structures
so usually i mean i'm sure that most of
us in here
when we look at a research question or a
clinical trial setting
we usually nowadays have two arms right
one is the tissue arm as you can see
in the in the set in the top part of the
the diagram you are you know stand you
have the
patient tissue your essential you know
all sorts of spatial technologies uh
and and you have the the can the tissue
you dissociate them into single cells
run through flow or unchosen
uh single sound sequencing or you do the
same thing for the blood bmc the kind of
thing as well
i'll take mainly you are thinking
whether this can be you know combined to
a model to predict
uh patient clinical outcome especially
in the immunotherapy era
but there is again why it's a gap gap is
that you know usually people like us
that doing
special technologies right so our
clinician friends or our
our scientists kalei actually have the
rna part on
sequencing data for the tissue and they
want you to validate this at all
even produce like a last figure for that
paper you know like
showing that this particular protein
also show on the tissues
either in the conventional ioc levels or
actually it's a multiple cell
setting so somehow not all the time
sometimes
you can't see the correlation in
concordance there's actually quite
common
right and i think the spatial
transformations really
solve this you know because you know you
will solve the heterogeneity of the
tissue you will know that whether these
are
where they are located and then later on
you know that why
are you not seeing this in the protein
levels
the other setting is that nowadays
single cells are rna sequencing is so
very common and then usually people run
through frost cytometry
high dimensional frosting complementary
or site of
side by side hand in hand and then to
show to the reviewer
you know sometimes it is it's correlated
sometimes concordance but sometimes not
right
and then when there is a little bit of
discordance you know the revival usually
will
start to question you i mean this is we
experience a lot right
so the the single cell data you know may
be
not so you know real because they are
dissociated those during the dissociated
process you actually
you know change the biology or
immunology of the cells
blah blah blah and then later on you
won't see this in the flow as well
so again you know spatial transitomics
actually solve this problem right
because you you remain intent
and then you you see these rna profile
signatures on the tissue and these
supposedly need to be
more natural than dissociated one
so what is facial transgenics in this
setting
we particularly talked about the digital
spatial profile profiling technology
from nanoshin
so this technology usually you you are
staying
at the protein levels for about three
markers we call it morphological
morphology marker
and you use this uh general marker to
actually visualize and navigate under
the microscope
then you know where do you want to
capture the gene profiles and signature
from the tissue
and then after that you get the you know
20 000 genes from
from the the original interest that you
selected and then you are sent through
either
encounter or ngs setting to actually get
the
the the sequencing sequencing data
so so this is very powerful and we
believe this is again changing in the
field
so so to how to to you know demonstrate
how do you use this new technology to
actually complement the current setting
for other spatial technology especially
in multiplex i hate helping
we will show you a study that we have
for um
kobe 19 story when i we particularly
look at this in this
uh in this study very the interesting
part is that the
cancer patient with cop19
so we call it the survival you know the
the
sound of this patient they actually
survive from chlorine and then later on
we get their tissue
so usually how this happen because they
are cancer patients
and then after this they recover from
kovi
they went to surgery so we get a
surgical tissue
there so there's one setting or or maybe
you
or they have they went for some biopsy
for certain kind of disease
so we get the biopsy as well so this is
question number one number two is that
we're also interested to understand
you know the pulmonary tissue compared
to the not extra pulmonary tissue
so that is also the other thing that we
think is very important to understand
the new micro environment of
the the kovi 19 setting so and
how do we dissect this particular
scientific question as you can see
we actually uh first use the very
conventional setting you know i have crn
scope to detect
where are this uh virus antigen or rna
on the tissue and then we look at that
particular region of tissue to use
spatial transformation
profiles and signature and and the
number three and number three is to use
multiplex ifc
uh to actually prove it this is also
happening in the protein levels
and i'll share two story with you first
of all first the first theory is the
insight to
immunity of survival i mean if i focus
on the survival based on special
taxonomics
the second part of the story is the
paper that we recently got
uh accepted in uh guard that is
comparing you know like uh
uh some patient that they have core
infections of corvinating and hiv
compared to the kobe 19 alone this is a
very interesting thing
so back to the story your digital
spatial profoundly
is basically you can see i mean for this
particular uh
section this is a colorectal cancer
patient that survived
from kovi 19 and then you can see we
stand c3 and c60 and just to look at the
ebio micro environment so we know how
to where to actually select the original
interest and then these are some of the
representative images that we actually
select the
original interest to get the 20 000
genes
and after we get the you know genes
profiles of
each of these uh each of this regional
interest
we do a deconvolute uh you know method
like cyber sort
so we yeah every single original
interest we actually got
they are you know sales abundancy or
a proportion of each of this immune cell
type i mean such
as you know in the cyber so we can we
can we can
uh differentiate into many many
different sub subclasses
such as the immune cells from you know
myeloid neurotic cell macrophages and
also t
cell b cells and each of this uh smaller
subset as well
and the other beauty of it is that we
also detect
inside through the the divide the
virus rna so including the spike
and also the rrf1
okay so uh to cut the long story short
we found that the sus cough
ii genes are very correlated to some of
these uh immune cells i mean in here is
like plasma cells and t-rex
that is really interesting to us and why
is it and then whether we can see
in in other settings so first of all we
we know where are the region that we can
detect
more our virus rna by using the spatial
transatomics and they are again you know
correlate to plasma cells and t-rex
right
so we go back to the protein levels we
first
stand the viral antigen by using
to detect the virus mp because this is
like more specific to the to the setting
yeah so as you can see this particular
patient
uh this is like their cancer tissue and
then we have a little bit of
normal colonic crypts in here with
normal
colon structures there we can you can
see in here
and they are green color meaning that
they are positive for viral
antigen and you can see another clip
here i hope you guys are seeing my uh
mouse so there is a there is another
normal
colonic strip here which is actually
negative so it serves as a very good
internal control so we know the actual
protein level we can see this as well
and of course we can also see some you
know the significant positive cells and
the fog species
kind of like t-rex that's surrounding
this area and then
we ask you know this is it like it is
just you know like
happened to be like that so we look
through the entire tissue and really
cannot found any other part of the
tissue that
showing you the antigen positivity again
you know especially this is uh a small
piece of normal
colony creeps there and the rest of the
tissues are tumor and
we really cannot see any tumor region
that have this
and this is kind of like validate our
our data in a spatial transatomic
setting
and and you know we still take it
further we we actually look at our nest
scope to actually insight to popping
this
uh uh virus rna and we again you know
in the adjacent normal column
we actually can see these positivity
cells okay
but not the rest of the tissue the rest
of tissue very very rare we can see that
spot
you know sporadics one or two cells
there
so this is really giving us a confidence
that this is real
and what we see in the spatial transit
economics really can be translated into
protein and also inside tool setting
and and not only that we actually look
at a few patients across multiple
organs and we can see this as well again
particularly i want to bring your
attention to the you know
one of this interesting equation that
you can see
at the left uh bottom corner this is
exactly what i showed you just now
you have uh you have a tumor region that
is negative for the
viral antigen but there's the next to it
the colonel creeps are positive
this is the same setting that i show you
and we can see in a spike antigen
protein has protein levels
as well and the one that we send to rna
scope that
have positivity we also send to our tpcr
to prove the positivity so it's like
multi-modal
modality to prove one particular
evidence
so and later on we also use another
special transcendence
platform to validate this so we run
through the email uh you know
so-called copy 19 public domain emu
response signature
and then we found that this particular
patient ammunition is like
there's one corner they're very average
again it's called related in concordance
to the corner that we see just now
and then we run through the rest of the
potential you know like email cells
uh signature and some of the cova
receptors as well
and only the b cells and plasmas you can
see here
they enrich in the same or similar kind
of region
that is really giving us another
confidence levels and look at the other
patient
and then you you can see that they are
the the enriched
uh uh regions are actually across the
the very red particular regions and you
can see in that about three but
the top right corners are we call it
like still
the focus area right and then again you
know the plus five sauce and pizza again
is very enriched in this particular
focus area
and then if you do uh you know like
unbiased uh
uh or maybe arbitrary you know
distribution into
all those all the regions in this
particular tissue into you know high
covalent response versus
low carbohydrate response and you can
see this uh igk
and ig hghm genes representing the
plasma cells
this is actually immunoglobulin genes is
really like
showing a very significant difference
here as you can see here
in the diagram so this is all the tissue
levels information
so we are thinking you know whether we
can actually prove you know like this we
can detect yes we can detect the you
know
enrichment here and we can detect viral
antigen
and uh rna here and if this immune
response is real and still there you
know so we actually design
experiment to actually look at ex vivo
stimulation of the
of this particular uh immune cell these
immune cells are extracted from
you know dissociated from the tissue
that we show you just now and then we
stimulate them or ex vivo by uh covet
peptide
and see whether we can trigger something
first of all you know usually this kind
of stimulation is a mix so
you you have uh myeloid cell fpc there t
cell b cells there
so we want to first check whether t
t-cells is really responding this we we
should see it we see a lot of activation
marker granzyme be
silly thirty-year and then we don't see
in a healthy kind of
tissue so this is this experiment is
working
and later on we actually run through a
single cell
experiment for this particular uh
setting so it runs through single cell
we know every single cells of this one
and then we know you know like that you
know some of these are t-cells
naive cells or regulatory t b cells and
myeloid population
and we try to map this single cell it
back into our
our our our tissue and we again see the
b
cells and t-rex again and reached in the
in the
in the region that will show you just
now and
go back to the protein levels and we
show you just now the colonic creep stay
positive for the anti
iron antigen and you can see that if you
can appreciate some of this particular
cells that next to the crypts which is
the epithelium
you can see them they are also green
color i mean of course they are
colloquialized with the red so they are
looks a bit yellow so what are these
cells this looks like immune cells
actually
so we stand you know of course we show
you the the final outcome here but we of
course
stream through a few of the the
candidate and at the end we know that
this is
cd14 positive but not c3 positive so
they are like myeloid and monoxide
kind of lineage and then we also know
that they are cd68 positive which is
like
kind of 3d macrophages and they are sd2
which is a viral
receptor positive as well so so this is
like you know
not surprised because i think some uh
reports also show that the virals can
directly infect
macrophages this could be a one of the
you know the mechanism that why the
virule can go through the whole body
because of the fpc or this thing
and we again you know like sometimes we
are trying to challenge our own data we
use multimodality
so we not only see in the protein levels
we also see in the rns called inside two
levels so this is gene level
so the gene we also detect the virus and
rna together with cd68 and sc2 on the
same cells that you can see
here so and at the end we run through
you know like another cohort which is
the postmortem cohort
we actually have about 20 somethings are
patient
and then we know that they are
multi-organs also that can be detected
detected this particular viral positive
macrophages authentic cells
and they are everywhere so as a brief
summary you know
spatial transfer thomas is really a good
technology to actually
you know complement the current spatial
technologies there is
very very exciting and it's a game
changer for
studying the emu micro environment so
for this particular study
is uh we actually show that the we
really can detect residuals
such as viral antigen rna even the
patient
has uh survive and recover from from
kovi
even up to three months okay so and then
we
we believe the email restaurant that we
detect here because we can prove it in
extreme setting
they are real and multiple papers in
this line actually have been you know
impressed or accepted invincible
so particularly i want to take another
five minutes or so
to actually show you the second story
about the hiv coin infection this is
actually
a paper that just got into gut recently
so you know we always you know wondering
you know the emu suppress
uh kind of selling whether this will
make the covida more
uh more that make the patient more you
know sustainable for
kobe or even they get covered whether
this will be more
likely to be a severe cases so our you
know
our collaborator from china they
actually when the
first when this pandemic first started
in wuhan they actually filed some of
this patient the first batch of tension
the hiv positive
so they are and then they see that some
of these patients actually survive very
long compared to the same batch of the
other patients so they are wondering why
and how
so they are collaborate with us to
actually look at email whether we can
see this in the email setting
so some of this issue we send to bulk on
this sequencing this is
this particular study is really like a
dogma kind of a
very good setting that we really have
about rnas facial and and protein and
i'm sure later on so the bowel onion
sequencing we actually can see that you
know the cov and hiv core infection
and they are very different from the
kobe 19 alone kind of setting
and this only happened in the liver in
kidney but not so much in the lung
setting
the lung is like you know you don't
really see a huge difference
and interestingly if you do a geo of it
you actually
can see that in the liver and kidney you
see a lot of this uh
t cells uh you know reduction and the
macrophages are kind of like activated
but not this again the phenomena cannot
be reproduced in the lung setting
and then of course we will do the
spatial transformations by using you
know nano strain dsp
and in here we actually you know select
you know this digital interest based on
again you know ch3 cd68 and also
cytokeratine to actually show the
morphology and and
and and we later i'll show you we will
analyze the cd3 reach and
macrophages which region separately and
in here the key thing in here
is that if you can see across these
three
organs only the t cell rate the t sound
reduction
and the increase of macrophages can be
only see
in liver and kidney but not in the lung
and the rest of the you know the rest of
the
immune cells such as b cells and ksl
remain you know no change i mean we
don't see a significant difference
between these two population
and we also we don't see others immune
cells again this is the data for spatial
transatomics and we deconvolute into
uh by using cybersaw and into multiple
immune cells
and the others immune system here is
just like the rest of the minor
population and we want to see this in
the spatial protein
levels as well so we stain our multiplex
i can see and again you can see that
you know the series if you look at cd3
and c20 cd206 which is represented in
macrophages
and here you can only see this reduction
on t
cells and increase of macrophages in the
extrapulmonary
tissue such as liver and kidney but not
in
in lung this lung is actually sometimes
even showing the opposite kind of cell
and if you go back to the bow on the
sequencing data
you can see that you know the the liver
and kidney showing a lot of these
macrophages and rich
ginge and and all those you know like
activate the t-cells genes that is
actually downregulated
and it can if you can look at a general
and the bigger pictures
it's also the showing the same kidney
liver showing the myeloid cells
activation
involvement in immune response but not
in the lung setting
and just to recap this is the dsp
setting you know you have morphology and
then your solid region address and then
you get the data they need our engines
right
so in here we look if you look at only
the cd3 risk region and then we look at
liver in here
we found that liver is really
interesting organs in this particular
uh cohort of patient that core infected
with
hiv and you can see that the the t
cells abundancy positively called
associated with the viral load
okay the viral law is actually
uh uh correlated to the to the t cells
only in the liver and only in the non
hiv setting because we know that hiv
is a little bit you know it is like
basically targeting the t
cells as this is a crc ccr5
mechanism right so so it's actually
making sense right so the
for the non-hiv patient we can see that
t cell is still functioning is
still responding to this one but not a h
but not a hiv setting
and you can see that in in in this one
as well
for the for the genes levels
classification or from the psp
and and also interestingly for the hiv
setting you can see the macrophages
instead of
rather than the t cells they are the one
that correlates to the viral low
so this basically gives us like a you
know hypothesis is that
the microphage is kind of compensating
the t cell impairment in the hiv patient
to fight the cloving and this may be you
know correlate to why they are surviving
better in this particular cohort
so again we are not trying to draw too
much attention
and conclusion from this small cohort
for biological and clinical
we're just trying to show this to the
public that is a first batch of
the patient in wuhan and this is like
some of the optoxy sample that we
collected
is a very precious kind of a medical
clinical
uh information that you want to share to
the public so again at the end we also
show this in the protein levels that we
we spend multiplex i have seen we see
the viral load is actually the green
color
is really you know uh associated with
the macrophages uh
percentage and these macrophages are
also expressing the activation markers
such as steve 80 and
86 so again you know i would already
show you you know we we think that you
know usually people think that you know
in this in
a coffee or either in hiv alone setting
their macrophages all this
can be impaired in a hiv study in fact
if you read
true there are many of them actually
reporting the macrophages can be long
life and resistant to actually
cytopathic effect
but you know in here we are just trying
to hypothesis that
hypothesize that they are probably
compensating the
t cell to find the coding
so this is my last slide just to
actually show you one of the
the website importer that we've made
through and then to actually uh
show levels in public data and feel free
to schedule qr code
i'd like to you know acknowledge our
pathology department national cancer
center
it's not a collaborator that an overseas
collaborator from china especially
to actually share with us the precious
data and tissue for studying the
the the the autopsy samples
uh thank you thank you very much and uh
i hope to welcome any question thank you
thank you so much dr young that was a
really really fascinating presentation
um we've had a slew of questions that
came in um through the chat
so hopefully we can get to them before
you have to to run off
um so one of the the questions that came
through from the beginning of the
presentation
um when you looked at the biopsies from
the cancer patients
were any of those cancer patients on any
immunotherapy
and um do you think that would have some
um you know correlation with the fact
that they did
um you know end up surviving covid or or
not
sorry israel can you repeat the question
i i mean like a little bit soft here
that i can't really
catch the first part of your question oh
yeah sure i will
repeat it so in the initial
biopsy samples that you got from
patients
that um have cancer and happen to have
covid um were any of those patients
on any targeted immunotherapies oh
no no they are i mean they're probably
having certain kind of treatment later
on but
this particular tissue that we got for
the surgical samples
they actually are considered treatment
knife because
they just get the surgery surgery and
then get the samples and then we started
the sample
but usually this patient later on they
may get some
treatment but it's actually after
they're actually the surgery it's a
post-surgery setting yeah
okay um and then a follow-up question to
that
that that came in from that part of your
presentation
um so in those patient biopsy samples
when the when you did
um the geomics digital spatial profiling
um you mentioned that there was the
present of some
presence of some t-rex in the tissue
do you think that that is you know just
indicative
of an immunosuppressive environment that
is caused by the presence of the tumor
or do you think that um having the t-rex
there
actually um helped these patients
recover from covid now that we know
you know looking back at some you know
severe
cases of covenant and cases where people
have actually passed away that
sort of a runaway overactive immune
response causes a lot of the
tissue damage ultimately
yeah in fact uh i think that is uh
that is exactly what you say you know i
think we believe the t-rex probably is
like hell like police
officers they actually come in to
actually make the particular region that
infected by the virus and and and they
tried to you know calm down the immune
response and cascade in there this is
just our hypothesis we don't not really
have a pro at the moment but uh but
t-race is also something that very uh
generally uh i would think that
difficult to study in in selling because
because as you can see we we show you
more on the b cells and plus muscle
training setting is like the signature
is more stronger
but the t-rex because it's part of the
t-cell sometimes the signal can be a bit
noisy
so um yeah so we we again you know we
we have the luxury to show you in the
multi multiple modality kind of setting
to actually prove one point
but uh uh that that is
again you know the the thing that we
want to promote right so
if you want to adopt something like this
it's good to actually show
in different angle and pointing pointing
to the same direction
that is make the evidence are stronger
and convincing
thank you so another question
came in during the middle of your
presentation
could you comment on the workflow for
the geomix digital spatial profiling
and how it might compare to other
spatial transcriptomic methods that you
have been exposed to i think um
for i think we actually oh i actually
didn't uh show this like i have a slide
actually uh showing one of our paper in
fact our one of our we actually have a
paper review
review paper last year to talk about uh
uh
different type different platform on
station transdominate the pros and cons
that kind of thing
i think the key thing i would say
advantages of nanostream
tsp is actually uh the technical battery
is lower i feel
it's easier to actually uh perform the
experiment and if you get the machine is
actually
uh you you probably are
easier to actually do that compared to
the rest of the technologies that
require a higher
technical barrier
and the other thing is also the dsp can
also do protein levels so i guess
at the moment there is no at least at
the moment there is no other platform
that can do uh
proteins and
side by side kind of setting
so another question that came in towards
the end of your presentation
on the hiv work which by the way is
really fascinating so
do you think that there can be anything
that can be extrapolated from that
that data if at all and i know it's a
small you know small sample size
um to suggest that a
innate immune response a robust innate
immune response
is is very important um you know in
preventing
severity of covid19 you know disease as
well as
you know um you know an early um you
know
death of some patients you know i um so
it you know
i particularly want to add to this
question too that i found it
really interesting um you know that
there was and obviously
you know with an hiv patient they're
going to have an
um you know a um lower t-cell response
because of the nature of the hiv
infection
but you know do you think there's
anything that can be extrapolated from
that
about you know the importance of of the
innate immune cells being activated
and being functional and you know kind
of um
sounding the alarm first and taking care
of a lot of the sars kobe 2 viral
infected cells before even t cells and b
cells get involved
yeah i i think uh first of all i mean as
you as
you say i mean this is a small cohort
and it's actually uh only from
from wuhan at the very beginning of the
pandemic and whether this is really mean
something to the general population
at the moment we are not very sure but
you know if you look at it
i would think that this data sort of
reasonable as well
because uh we all know that you know the
one of the complications and one of the
severe
uh covid uh setting the mechanism is
because of the cytokine stone the the
emus kind of like over reaction the kind
of thing
so it is uh it's not really bizarre to
actually
see this on this emu suppressive setting
uh because of
of this one they probably have a better
outcome or maybe
not so severe the kind of thing i i
think i i don't think this is something
very difficult to actually conceive what
we actually want to bring out in here is
that
so you can see this particular in
particular
immune i would say particular immune
response immunity that we we
discover very strong in liver for this
patient
but not so strong in in kidney but still
quite okay
compared to lung is totally in the lung
is totally not in this
kind of theory so
so we not very sure in the multi-organ
setting
uh different immunity from different
organs how to you actually really
directly contribute to the systemic or
general
health of this particular patient we are
just you know like
trying to report that there is this this
thing
and and and require further study to
understand how
actually this is going to contribute for
you know the the infections and also
later on maybe vaccines kind of setting
excellent and that's a perfect segue to
the last question
which is related to vaccines so now that
we're seeing a massive rollout
of you know vaccinations um for sars
kobe 2
and reports are coming out of certain
side effects
um and you know potential rare cases
you know where there could be um you
know severe side effects
how do you think um spatial
transcriptomics can be used
um to resolve some of these complicated
cases
of you know potential side effects with
a vaccine and along with that question
also you know what is the next direction
of of your research you know that that
you're going to focus on with
the spatial transcriptomic tool
i think there's a thankful question i
think that that is actually uh something
that we are definitely interested to
study i mean i i think uh there are some
groups already
started to collect something some of
these samples
you know uh it could be the same setting
right if you go back to the slide that
we show you you know we have post-mortem
setting
and which is the decisions and also the
survival right
so in the vaccinated setting it's also
the same so there are people that after
the vaccination they actually go in for
surgery so we can get this kind of
tissue
the sound of this patient i mean it may
not directly because of the vaccines the
ms
of this patient actually or this time of
this healthy donor they're actually
having certain kind of accident or
something so they'll have they have the
post-mortem
uh samples
so i think the digital spatial
profoundling the technology can be
applied to study this
cohort and to understand i guess the key
question at the moment first is that to
understand
the viral distribution i think i mean of
course we can we can learn this from the
blood
but the organs specific setting is
actually uh
i would think this is a very important
piece of information
for the scientific community this is
number one and number two is the
if you detect this uh virals uh either
rna or or
or or antigen and and they are
uh correspondence uh immune response and
what are the female cells and while
immunogenes that enrich in those
regions and whether there is any uh
multi uh
organ specific kind of setting like i
showed you just now
it will be a very important and precious
scientific information to actually help
us moving forward
maybe preparing for the next pandemic if
there is any
hopefully well thank you so much
we really appreciated the talk oh it
looks like there's one more
question that is coming in really
quickly and hopefully we can get to it
before we have to wrap up
um so do you have any plans or do you
have access to any samples
um of uh you know patient biopsies
of say um solid organ transplant
recipients
who have contracted sars kobe 2
to understand what is the um effect if
any
of people that are on long long-term
immunosuppressives
and how that affects the outcome of
coca-19
let me think i think at the moment the
short answer is no but i guess if you
really want we can approach some of the
collaborators
for that and of course in the audience
if anyone want to you know like what we
first collaborate with us on these kind
of samples i mean we are more than
welcome to help
excellent so on that note i'd like to
thank you
dr young for joining us um for the
excellent presentation and also i'd like
to again thank
dr eugenia ong who was on earlier and
again
for those of you listening to this lab
roots coronavirus
virtual seminar series webinar if you
have
questions that didn't get answered the
folks at the labyrinth will follow up
and again thank you so much for
thank you
[Music]